My magic is invincible With
this power, I'm a magic knight I've risen to the rank of captain and
even become the lowest bargaining for an unparalleled business
I'm a great man who possesses both wealth and power
Magician, my body,
I won't end
here With this magic that can be revived over and over again and the investigative committee
a
[Applause]
[Music]
Yeah yeah yeah
Wood
You can't even see me
Why why can I open it with an attack
On top of that, the magic of sharks
can be hidden, but the machine is hidden, isn't it
?  It's a hernia. It's a
good volume.
So they u
i that san as it is
[music]
painting magic rest Rikushi Otono Izumi
The
title is Drowning Commander,
isn't it?